I get the 1.91, so if we take 26.97 ± 1.91.
We find that this claim over here is well within this confidence level.
There is no reason to doubt that this would be a wrong claim based on the sample that we've drawn.
Now again, just to pay attention here.
In any given night there might be a reason that particularly young people come
or particularly old people to come--maybe on the style of music played.
Just taking a sample on one night is not fair as a statistician.
It should be really independent, so you should go and in on random nights
and take a random person each night.
But leaving this aside, I hope you were able to follow this.
If you are, you're now able to test based on data hypothesis and accept or rejection.
This is a very powerful technique. In the next final exercise, you get to program all this.